[Música]
turno de la cultura en France 24 estoy
Yanira Gómez Muñoz y hoy es mi honor
acompañarles por última vez eso
siguiento Nando una despedida desde el
encanto de Colombia que sin temor a
exagerar es junto a Lilo y Stitch y
frozen la mejor película Disney de los
últimos 20 años tras la compra de Pixar
el estudio empezó a superar sus
exotismos para engendrar en estas ramas
cintas como Ratatouille coco y Luca más
conscientes de las identidades que
asimilan así que puede ser porque lo
balizacion pero encantada un paso en lo
multicultural para brindar una animación
hecha por locales y migrantes con limón
o el Miranda de ascendencia
puertorriqueña a la batuta de las
canciones
[Música]
claro que encantó tiene elementos no es
lo que la hace especial
qué es la Rúa o la biodiversidad exalta
el gusto por la trama sin villano pero
con una casa con vida propia algunos
dicen que esto es un sancocho de
regiones una mezcla pero un país de
desplazados forzados por décadas de
guerra solo podía dar más representación
y familia la más numerosa de Disney
[Música]
no puedo hacerlo yo te ayudo las gatas
ya me contaron todo
hasta en los momentos más
cuando menos lo esperas
[Música]
pero no tener un amigo no volando no me
quiere
oír a la matriarca en español es otra
capa de lectura por eso el West Side
Story de nuestro siglo tiene diálogos
sin subtitular en un reconocimiento a la
comunidad latina en Estados Unidos a
Steven Spielberg no le pasó por alto que
además de ser una riqueza es la
expresión natural de los boricuas
Charles al enfrentarse a los Jets y más
cuando en su versión hay un elenco de
origen hispano entre ellos el Bernardo
de David Álvarez 101 evolución respecto
a la de 61 con la memoria del fallecido
electricista Stephen Sondheim Spielberg
cumple con su sueño de un musical en un
diciembre lleno de tradición acción
traición fantasía y drama
Iván gorda no
[Música]
es difícil hacer un podio antes 10
estrenos de altura y con las firmas y en
cambio en Ridley Scott Guillermo del
Toro Paolo Sorrentino y Adam McKay en
estadios no me meteré en este Pantanal
aunque la belleza y la inspiración la
sirven en Netflix el poder del perro y
fue la mano de Dios que entrelazan
psicología ya sea para derrumbar
estereotipos de víctimas del patriarcado
como para contar una juventud en Nápoles
la de Sorrentino salvada por el propio
Maradona en esa línea biografica están
rey Richard y viviendo Ricardo la
primera sobre como el padre y el entorno
de Venus y Serena Williams influyó de
forma titánica en su tenis mientras que
en la casa Gucci están el último francés
nuestra época que los herederos de la
marca de moda la siento en un insulto el
asesinato de su familiar Mauricio
muak
[Música]
top best
en otro registro de debilidad por los
fantásticos lo satírico y lo Noir
rematan Spider-Man 2 lock up in I'm
alice está haciendo el multiverso y la
salvación de la tierra y embaucando en
una feria que es a la vez remake y
tributo a la novela como ha dicho del
Toro feliz de unir horror y
vulnerabilidad humana por supuesto el
rey resurgido es el Matrix de las white
que aunque en su dirección no esté Lili
promete perdurar otros 20 años más
[Música]
preciso la guinda a dos décadas de una
saga que Harry Potter va saborearla este
género en Hogwarts pero desvío más y en
una reunión entre sus actores entrenados
más que dirigidos por un entonces Chris
Columbus que ignoraba que superaría su
propio éxito home alone luego de 2 horas
y media de intentar convencer allí que
Rowling de su rodaje no recibió más que
bendiciones
y realismo a sus personajes
bien por la piedra filosofal un primero
de enero pero sin duda el mayor regalo
ha sido ser testigos de un nuevo legado
por parte de la estrella del musical
Josephine Baker si bien el escritorio y
medio en 2013 el empujón a un homenaje
si hoy es la sexta mujer en descansar en
el machista panteón de Francia es por
una intachable vida en contra del
racismo y a favor de las libertades y
todo iniciando por el espectáculo nacida
en Missouri entre miserias y con dos
matrimonios precoces y fallidos como le
falló prodway Francia no fue para Baker
su país de acogida sino su país a secas
allí nacionalizada no solo fue la
cabaretista hola madre adoptiva de 12
niños sino la subteniente del Ejército
del Aire en la resistencia contra los
fascismos en 1963 se uniría los derechos
civiles o patria sin embargo solo en la
nación golista pudo ser la Venus de
ébano dueña de su destino
[Música]
Josephine Baker tenía dos amores pero
sobre todo una vida impresionante
eso es lo que nos cuenta Josephine B en
el escenario el viaje de una chica de
Missouri nacida en la pobreza que se
convirtió en una estrella mundial una
mujer libre y valiente
[Música]
resistía porque tenía en la cabeza una
única cosa
70 es decir
ayudar a Francia
fue recompensada por ello y obtuvo
varias medallas y estas medallas las
llevo a Washington para seguir a Martin
Luther King en su lucha por los derechos
de los afroamericanos
[Música]
está lucha contra el racismo las y yo
haciendo desde su casa en el campo y con
ternura formó una familia de niños
adoptados huérfanos de todas partes del
mundo
y junto a soneclub Brahim de dónde
vienes ya 50 años después Brahim
recuerda esta educación peculiar allí me
estaba dando tercero es el séptimo de
los 12 hijos de Josephine Baker a los
que ella llamaba su tribu arcoiris
[Música]
este está utopía y este espíritu de
resistencia que ahora llevan a Josephine
Baker al panteón
ya volviendo a la región aún faltan días
para febrero pero en Río de Janeiro
bombos y lentejuelas aguardan que la
pandemia no les arrebate otro carnaval
es más rezando contra las variantes
esperan poder celebrar una legendaria
fiesta en Mulán 2 el regreso de la de
1919 cuando las vi pestañuela les
cancelo entonces su vida la samba este
paralelismo es el tema de la escuela
Unidos do Viradouro en cuyo desfile si
la crisis y las autoridades no permiten
piensan vitorear la felicidad contenida
por ahora lo hacen desde el ensayo y el
samba City el patio portuario que acoge
la gran familia de carnavales costureros
soldadores y carpinteros los más
perjudicados por el freno
carnaval de 1919
para la economía de Río de Janeiro para
la sociabilidad de las personas porque
la gente volvió a su normalidad a
retomar las calles
el mayor carnaval de este último siglo
nos lleva hasta el Caribe donde la banda
reggae puertorriqueña Cultura Profética
no solo lanzó el tema desamor fuiste
cruel sino casa 2022 festejará sus 25
años de trayectoria con su preciada y
resistente isla Boriken como escenario
de concierto emblema junto a Bogotá y
Lima
[Música]
y cerca aunque siempre entre París y La
Habana las voces de las hermanas y de
allí también resurgieron con made of
gold su primera creación en estudio en
compañía del británico para salió en un
avance que para ellas desde tercer disco
sí pero sobre todo una reconexión con
sus antepasados y las brujas esa magia
dicen es su nueva música
[Música]
llegados al final como les avance me
gustaría dedicarles un gracias inmenso
por haber estado durante más de 4 años
al otro lado de esa cámara dejándome
expresar una cultura libre que enseña y
alimenta un compromiso social las más de
50 personas entrevistadas fueron
cómplices de ello pero jamás hubiera
sido posible si los equipos de Master
maquillaje graficación y revés además en
estos camarógrafos mi compañera leovel
seguirá cuidando de este propósito
mientras que yo le dejo dos contenidos
extras con su nieta athmane cuyo álbum
es un bombazo les digo adiós y como
expresa ella pues con el último día
disco pronto nos vemos en esta casa
France24 desde otros lares gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]